ryan phillippe is enjoying a father-son
getaway and it is goals i love that part
of being a dad the 46-year-old shared
some snaps with his 17-year-old son
deacon on instagram including many pics
from their time at macaulay warm springs
in new mexico the father-son duo posed
for some shirtless selfies and is it
just me or do these two totally look
like twins i love it the crash star also
shared these photos of the stunning
landscape
as well as a solo shot of them enjoying
the clear water
i'm still very much in tune with what
the youth is about today the caption the
rocky uphill hike was well worth the
warm woodland baptism that followed and
deacon he slid into the comments of his
dad's post writing quote and the vittles
of course ryan shares deacon as well as
his 21 year old daughter ava with his
ex-wife rhys witherspoon he's also dad
to 10 year old kai from a separate
relationship while reece has an
eight-year-old son tennessee with her
husband jim toth in october 2020 the
exes celebrated deacon's 17th birthday
together complete with cake and a
special rendition of happy birthday
back in 2016 ryan opened up to e.t about
co-parenting with rhys specifically over
the holidays
quote we trade off you have to get to
that point as a divorced parent as any
parent where you're not putting yourself
first you want the kids experience to be
its own and not like well i need to have
my time we have been very good about
that and it appears deacon gets tons of
quality time with his famous mom too yes
it's amazing back in july 2020 the
little fires everywhere star celebrated
her son's first ever single long run by
posting this video of herself dancing to
the song on tick-tock
i should make up a tick-tock socks
no
no
she captioned the clip quote when your
kid has his first single out
[Music]
you